est-ce que je peux donner son nom c'est
à vous de voir Thierry
on termine cette émission avec notre
terrienne du samedi soir
[Musique]
Flavie Flament bonsoir
j'ai adoré ma vie d'enfant et
d'adolescente en Normandie j'ai déclaré
ça dans Madame Figaro en juillet 2002 et
aujourd'hui le livre que vous publiez
chez latex la consolation fait voler en
éclat cette idyllique tableau Flavie en
effet il lève le voile sur une enfance
dictée par la folie d'une mère
dépressive et manipulatrice prête à
jeter sa fille dans les bras du premier
prédateur venu en échange d'un court
instant de strass et de paillettes ce
passé Flavie vous l'aviez refoulé effacé
de votre mémoire mais il a refait
surface vous dites que ça a commencé par
un malaise boulevard Malesherbes vous
croyez devenir folle ça faisait quelques
temps déjà que j'étais en souffrance
enfin je l'avais toujours été mais
j'étais incapable d'en connaître
réellement l'origine et d'ailleurs je je
me construisais une vie où j'imaginais
une vie même un passé même une famille
finalement qui n'avait en réalité jamais
existé et la mort de mon grand-père a
été déterminante parce que c'était la
seule personne qui pour moi représentait
un lien secure c'était une personne qui
m'aimait sans condition et ce jour-là
boulevard Malesherbes je j'ai vécu un
premier surgissement un premier
jaillissement de ce que l'on appelle la
mémoire traumatique qui sont
effectivement tous ces souvenirs intacts
qui sont refoulés au fond de soi dans un
coin de votre âme c'est une sorte de
fantôme c'est un assaillant il est sur
votre épaule il vient troubler tous vos
moments de bonheur il vient gâcher votre
regard sur l'existence il vous harcèle
mais vous ne savez pas qu'il est et vous
ne savez pas ce qui se passe c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai cru devenir
folle les malaises vont se répéter
régulièrement avec des crises de panique
bientôt des flashs vous voyez un tissu
vert un ciel bleu derrière un mur blanc
jusqu'au jour ou après avoir tout essayé
vous rencontrez un psychiatre qui vous
demande de revenir avec un album photo
de votre enfance mais reprenons les
choses par le commencement
Flavie Lecanu c'est notre vrai nom vous
naissez le 2 juillet 1974 à Valognes
dans la Manche votre père ancien
footballeur boss à la SNCF et votre mère
s'occupe d'enfants de la DASS à la
maison vous avez deux frères 4D
on ne peut pas dire que vos parents vous
portent une grande attention vous
racontez dans votre livre qu'un soir
après un match de foot ils vous disent
reste dans la voiture on va boire un
coup et ils vous oublie dans la voiture
à un moment vous sortez de la voiture il
fait nuit vous avez peur vous les
rejoignez et vous calcule pas c'est en
parlant un jour en expliquant mais je me
souviens avoir couru avoir ouvert cette
cette porte être arrivée avoir vu que
des que des jambes d'adultes parce que
j'étais minuscule et avoir traversé ce
salon et j'ai souvenir de quelque chose
qui vraiment est douloureux et c'est là
qui m'a été rapporté effectivement d'une
façon d'ailleurs assez déroutante parce
que absolument déculpabiliser c'est là
que j'ai entendu bah oui Flavie ce
jour-là effectivement c'est dingue que
tu t'en souviennes dans ta vie oubliée
il y a autre chose c'est que le soir
quand vous êtes au lit votre père passe
dans la chambre de vos deux frères pour
leur faire un bisou
et vous il vous calcule toujours pas si
vous êtes là tout seul en train de de
vous enfouir dans votre oreiller pour
pour pleurer il y avait une une relation
avec mon père je dis avec Papa
d'ailleurs parce que je lui porte
toujours un véritable amour mais il y
avait un malaise quand on était ensemble
et on évitait les moments où on pouvait
se retrouver tous les deux c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense tous les
soirs quand il est embrasser mes frères
au lieu de prendre le couloir et de
venir m'embrasser moi il redescendait
l'escalier directement votre mère est
beaucoup plus sévère quand elle vous
reproche d'avoir pris du cul comme elle
dit elle vous oblige à des régimes elle
vous oblige à des peser et quand arrive
le dessert à table elle vous dit va dans
la voiture comme ça tu vas pas craquer
oui c'est à dire que le mon poids
devient une obsession avec la balance du
matin avec une observation permanente
des courbes de mon corps mais en plus ça
vous coupe de l'enfance c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes déjà dans la restriction au
moment où vous êtes en train de tout
goûter quoi et elle adore cette mer
quand les hommes plus âgés vous relu que
ça les moustique quoi en fait je me suis
souvent interrogée essayez de comprendre
les raisons qu'il y avait qui auraient
pu expliquer de ce comportement et je ne
veux pas les chercher donc j'imagine
qu'effectivement il y avait un ennui
heureusement votre mère organise des
week-end à Paris entre filles alors
c'est pas le Louvre c'est pas la Tour
Eiffel c'est pas l'Arc de Triomphe mais
c'est des enregistrements d'émissions de
télévision comme Champs-Élysées par
exemple son truc c'est d'approcher des
célébrités elle veut vivre une vie
qu'elle n'aurait pas pu toucher du doigt
si je n'avais pas été ce que j'étais à
13 ans votre mère vous emmène au Cap
d'Agde alors devant tous ces gens à poil
devant tous ces sexes vous passez vite
de l'étonnement à l'écorrement à la
nausée et c'est là qu'un photographe
vous branche vous et votre mère
d'ailleurs vous l'en faire des essais
avec vous votre mère est aux anges les
essais sont un succès et rendez-vous est
pris pour faire de vraies photos et dès
lors tous les jours votre mère vous
dépose à 14h chez le photographe en
disant je la récupère à quelle heure
vous passez l'après-midi que c'est
photographe oui
à quelle heure et je me souviens déjà
toute petite enfin j'avais 13 ans mais
dit mais je suis plus un bébé quoi et
puis jusqu'au jour où il ouvre
votre mère lâche votre main est dit je
la récupère à quelle heure comme si de
rien n'était elle dit exactement la même
phrase alors le photographe commence par
vous emmener sur la plage pour que vous
apatiez des femmes pour lui vous êtes
tétanisé devant ces femmes nues il vous
décrit leur sexe etc enfin bon et là il
s'énerve et il vous ramène dans son
appartement et là il vous viole deux
fois une fois sur le balcon et une fois
sous la douche
il commence sur le balcon et il m'emmène
sous la douche c'est le même jour et
je c'est là que je
recompose finalement le film puisque
vous parliez de ces images qui me
revenaient d'une façon totalement
désordonnée
ce mur en crépi blanc et se coin de ciel
bleu c'est précisément le moment où je
suis allongée sur le balcon et c'est ce
que je vois une serviette verte et c'est
bien ce bout de tissu que vous avez revu
à partir du boulevard Malesherbes quand
les choses ont commencé à remonter la
surface violet à 13 ans c'est à dire
morte de l'intérieur
fissuré morte pas complètement
heureusement parce que il y a toujours
une flamme en moi et puis surtout je
pense qu'il y a il y a il y a déjà ce
fameux phénomène extraordinaire que l'on
méconnait encore peut-être de la mémoire
traumatique qui fait que ce que je suis
en train de vivre finalement je ne suis
pas là pour le vivre j'ai abandonné
j'ai abandonné mon corps j'ai abandonné
poupette cette petite fille que j'étais
le surnom de me donner mon grand-père je
l'ai abandonné ce jour-là sur le balcon
et et j'ai c'est une dissociation en
fait c'est le cerveau qui est
extraordinaire qui fait que lorsque
votre santé psychique est mise en danger
votre cerveau va vous permettre à un
moment donné de ne plus être dans la
sensation donc vous n'êtes plus rien
vous êtes entre les bras d'un pervers
vous êtes dans les mains d'un pédophile
et vous n'êtes pas là
alors vous savez que ces séances photos
permettent à votre mère de briller alors
vous allez pas lui dire maman je peux me
faire violer l'après-midi vous lui dites
j'en ai marre en fait de passer mes
après-midi enfermés avec ce type je
préférerais aller me baigner et votre
mère vous répond quand on prend un
engagement on va jusqu'au bout c'est
vrai quand on prend un engagement on va
jusqu'au bout c'est ce que je suis en
train de faire aujourd'hui
alors voilà tous les jours jusqu'à la
fin des vacances vous irez vous faire
violer par le célèbre photographe voilà
je à me faire violer je suis violée
c'est important pardon tirer mais une
victime ne se fait pas violer comme on
se fait une couleur de cheveux ou comme
on se fait refaire les dents une victime
est violée quand j'entends Flavie
Flament à vous avoir été violée c'est
pas à moi d'avouer c'est au coupable de
faire la veuve justement puisque on est
là ce coupable pourquoi vous donnez pas
son nom je ne peux pas donner son nom
parce que j'ai aujourd'hui 42 ans et que
j'avais selon la loi française jusqu'à
l'âge de 38 ans pour pouvoir me
retourner contre mon bourreau donc ce
qu'on peut dire au passage pardon Flavie
mais c'est que il y a des députés et des
sénateurs qui ont voulu porter ce délai
à 48 absolument à 48 ans et ça a été
rejeté c'était en 2014 si la loi a été
passée vous pourriez dire le nom de ce
photographe aujourd'hui parce que oui et
je ne peux pas le faire aujourd'hui
parce que je suis non seulement victime
mais je pourrais être en plus accusé de
diffamation est-ce que je peux donner
son nom c'est à vous de voir
il a aujourd'hui 83 ans je suis pas si
regarde la télé mais tu es un bel [__]
connard
le 19 juin 1988 vous êtes élu Miss ok
magazine sur M6 vous partez à Tahiti
avec votre mère ça se passe pas mal oui
ça se passe plutôt bien il y a un mec
quand même qui essaye de vous coincer
dans l'ascenseur mais à un moment la
porte s'ouvre il sort oui est-ce que je
relate là à travers cette situation
c'est que
j'ai déjà vécu
le viol et et en fait les prédateurs
sexuels reconnaissent leur victime
reconnaissent des des jeunes femmes qui
dont l'intégrité a déjà été piétiné et
effectivement ce jour là j'échappe de
justesse à une agression sexuelle
l'hiver suivant vous allez en colonie de
vacances à la montagne dans le train
vous rencontrez un garçon plus âgé que
vous
vous l'aimez bien et à un moment il va
rentrer dans les dans les toilettes du
train et vous lui faites un bisou
des toilettes il vous pénètre le fait de
ne pas pouvoir parler le fait de ne pas
pouvoir être entendu le fait de ne pas
pouvoir compter parfois sur un entourage
qui prendrait notre défense fait que on
ne sait plus dire non c'est ce qui s'est
passé ce jour-là dans le train je ne
pense pas que ce garçon était mal
intentionné à mon endroit mais je pense
surtout que je n'ai pas su dire non
parce que je ne savais pas ce que
c'était que dire non parce que je ne
savais pas que ce corps qui était le
mien finalement n'appartenait qu'à moi
et n'appartenait à personne d'autre
voilà vous enfouissez tout ça au plus
profond de votre mémoire les weekends à
Paris n'ont pas cessé avec votre mère
vous allez aux Champs-Élysées alors vous
montez vous descendez les champs
l'objectif c'est séduire les hommes
alors votre mère vous a appris à sourire
à jouer avec vos cheveux un tortiller du
cul à lancer des œillades mais ce qu'il
faut dire quand même c'est qu'à l'époque
là elle me couchait pas avec les mecs
que vous allumez pas du tout oui mais je
pense que chacun doit rester à sa place
dans une relation parents-enfants moi je
crois pas au concept mère copine je n'y
crois pas et moi j'ai été justement sous
couvert d'une sorte d'image fabuleuse
d'un couple super mère fille qui sont
aussi bien en fait se cacher en réalité
une véritable relation d'emprise
elle fait la gueule vous savez quand on
quand on est en manque d'amour on ferait
n'importe quoi pour que nos parents nous
aiment un jour vous avez toutes les deux
ici à la Plaine Saint-Denis là où ils
sont tournés la plupart des émissions de
télévision en espérant y rencontrer un
célèbre animateur
vous êtes perdu au milieu de la foule
des femmes votre mère vous pince les
hanches en vous poussant vers lui comme
ça elle dit mais parle-lui c'est surtout
que le lendemain de ça parce que elle
avait été obligée de me pincer les
hanches pour qu'un moment donné je fasse
un bon en avant de douleur et que je
demande ce [__] d'orthographe dont je
me foutais royalement le lendemain on
était dans le train et elle me dit tu te
rends compte si j'avais ta gueule et si
tu avais mon intelligence et ça aussi ça
fait partie de ces phrases qui qui m'ont
poursuivi très longtemps où j'ai eu le
sentiment de n'être rien ou en tout cas
d'être un physique qui était entretenu à
coup de régime mais qui avait rien à
l'intérieur de moi alors elle considère
qu'elle a une vie de merde un jour elle
est devant la gazinière elle tourne le
bouton en disant je vais mourir c'est un
moment de désespoir je pense aussi que
c'était quelqu'un qui
était en proie à un profond désespoir
dont j'essaye absolument pas de
connaître la cause mais mais oui ce
jour-là elle elle a tourné le bouton du
gaz vous la prenez dans vos bras et ça
vous révulse oui parce que vous êtes
quand même même si vous êtes dans la
souffrance capable d'identifier ce qui
vous font du mal et il y a des peaux qui
sont douces au toucher et qui rassurent
et il y en a d'autres qui sont froides
et qui font peur à l'âge de 16 ans vous
rencontrez un homme chez qui vous allez
passer des week-ends
ma mère est censée ma copine donc je me
retrouve à avoir une vie qui n'est pas
du tout de la vie que je devrais avoir à
l'âge de 14 ans ou à l'âge de 15 ans et
du coup quand ma mère regarde des hommes
ce sont des hommes de son âge et elle
trouve du charme à un homme qui
effectivement a plus de 25 ans plus que
moi et
finalement
une histoire s'installe absolument folle
ou je pars certains weekends chez lui et
entre temps
s'installe une relation épistolaire
entre lui et moi sauf qu'en réalité
c'est pas moi et dans les lettres elle
dit que vous avez hâte de le revoir elle
vient me voir et elle me dit tu sais si
tu veux lui écrire moi je pense que tu
devrais écrire ce que j'ai écrit ma
lettre et mieux rédiger ça ça passera
mieux ce sera mieux comme ça et donc du
coup il m'arrive parfois à l'heure de
des devoirs de réécrire de mon écriture
la lettre qu'elle a qu'elle a rédigé oui
je me retrouve avec cet homme son odeur
d'homme perdu veuf seul émus la
quarantaine
un homme triste heureusement
heureusement au milieu de tout simple à
vivre vous pouvez compter sur un
formidable tuteur de résilience c'est
votre grand-père il est au courant de
rien lui sauf que
il
a 7 de me faire voir l'existence il a
cette façon de m'aimer d'un amour que je
considère comme incommensurable dans ma
vie c'est un soleil donc je sais qu'on
peut tendre vers le soleil je sais qu'à
un moment donné on peut marcher et qu'on
peut choisir son trottoir donc au fond
de moi toujours je vais aller me
réchauffer à son soleil à lui c'est la
raison pour laquelle tout est parti
quand il s'est éteint vous voyez alors
aujourd'hui ça va mieux non la
psychothérapie vous a permis de sortir
de votre dépression Flavie poupette la
petite fille que j'étais m'a permis de
sortir de tout ça parce que j'ai un jour
choisi d'aller la chercher au fond de
moi est-ce que vous voyez votre mère non
plus
difficiles pour guérir on est obligé de
couper les liens avec ce qui nous est
toxique ce que je voudrais dire avant de
finir c'est que le livre est super bien
écrit mais vraiment et il y a beaucoup
de témoignages on en lit beaucoup
celui-là est super bien écrit vous avez
vraiment un don pour écrire merci merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu